[Music]
[Applause]
I never thought I would say this the
former head coach at Duke the Hall of
Famer winning his coach of all time Mike
shazefski back on the program where are
you right now
I'm in my uh home office what is in
there that might surprise me
oh
a lot the Dream Team autographed ball
the all the Olympic
uh autographed balls
national championships
Big Time posters uh if you had to grab
one thing
what would you grab I'd grab my my
family uh there's one of my family
at the London Olympics uh where we had
all my grandchild one was not here yet
and uh so I got that's the highest
picture here I love my family but I'd
grab the Dream Team ball
I know but that's what separates the two
of them
who do you get to yell at now because
like the mailman or the uh you know
person delivering the uh the pizza
delivery guy you gotta have somebody uh
have to yell at right yeah I don't yell
anymore I uh uh that's why I'm doing the
show I figured I'm gonna say
if I've gotten rid of it for good if I
don't yell at you you're like a witness
test this to uh whether I would yell
again oh so the this is the new and
improved the calm Mike shashavski
why would you say that's new and
improved
um
I've heard about those practices coach
those four practices to make people
better
I remember leightner telling me he goes
oh you guys don't get to see when he
gets mad at us or here and I said I
don't know I'd love to and he goes no
you wouldn't
no well that was 30 years ago so a big
thing throughout the years you have to
keep adapting
with how you communicate and uh it's
different really I bet I've done it 15
times how you because kids are different
in different
at different time periods
and how do you get your message across
while still holding them accountable
yeah
they have to be held accountable uh in
order to get better the role that social
media played in the latter part of your
career
how tough is that to talk to kids who
are being spoken to or they're reading
social media you should get more shots
or you're not any good or use transfer
how much of that come into play with you
now social media is huge now there's a
positive part of it and and a negative
the positive is we have the best social
media in college sports and uh and so
they're they're promoted well they're
they learn how to use social media their
names are out there you know there's a
positive aspect to it especially if you
monitor it the right way the negative is
if you
uh well if you listen to the voices of
unknown people who
tweet you and you know get get you and
and so we had a thing you know where we
would talk about one voice you know like
listen to the voice of our program not
to The Voice the outside uh voices and
uh but that's difficult uh that's that
that's really difficult so there's no
question that social media has an impact
a huge impact on on these kids
positively and somewhat negatively
how many home games will you attend this
year
I will not be in Cameron in person for
any home games and uh I'll be either the
first two I've been at home uh and uh
but I'll probably be in my office and
watch them in my office and uh we also
have some charity things that uh we're
not racing a lot of money for the Emily
Center and also for the V Foundation by
having
uh some people come in and have a dinner
and then watch the game with me in my
office and uh you'd be shocked yeah we
have
for the Emily uh we have six events like
that or they bring in they were
auctioned and they bring in seventy
thousand dollars each and then uh the V
Foundation there are two of them
and I think it's a hundred and fifty
thousand for each one so what the heck
you wanna you wanna get one I don't know
well are you giving me one will I be on
scholarship for the first no they all
know oh no okay there are no charitable
scholarships okay maybe a walk-on maybe
just a maybe I could serve the dinners
just I just you know what how about that
I was just gonna say that there's
there's there's a chance we can get in
here
how are you though I'd love to observe
you watching a game
I'm good you know I watch it more yeah
analytically you know like uh uh and
then make some notes
and then uh uh if John John Shire who's
the the coach and son a great job uh
John and I are really close and uh most
of the time we'll get together not right
after the game but the next day and
spend a few minutes and and you know no
earth-shattering things like you should
run a different defense or offense but I
might notice
just something about one of the kids on
the team or uh and and just listen to
him yeah you know where his head is at
because uh you know he's really good
man not good he's like really good but
uh he can bounce things off of me and
I'll give him an honest answer and use
the uh
experience that I've had uh but you know
Dan He I've known John since he's 16.
and you know he's was a great player a
national champion in our program and he
was with me for nine years
as a coach so we're uh we're very close
and uh I I just think he's I really
think he's terrific
I don't know if there's any coach in
America who's got more pressure on him
than John does
yeah you know uh for him uh he's always
been the top player you know he's the
player of the year in the state of
Illinois a state champion
uh John is accustomed to having the
spotlight on him and I think he was born
to be in pressure or what other people
think our pressure is pressure and I
think he looks at as as uh
a great opportunity and I think he
handles things
like very well as a player I would say
he's he's kind of unflappable you know
he he never got too excited he never got
down and
and he did something as a player that we
don't get very much anymore and that is
somebody on the court who can make
decisions about your team in the moment
it's happening that they understand time
score he's got a report who's in and
instead of you know waiting for a
timeout or a stop action for a coach to
tell them and
those type of players
are invaluable I mean they're they're
just aren't as many like that uh and and
he he was one of them for me you missed
practice or games more
uh interaction uh not games I I really I
coached
so many games you know I don't I don't
miss crowd or anything like that I you
know the thing I've loved in my career
is the interaction and the relationships
with the players and and uh the staff uh
and the infrastructure around our team
where you're you know you're you're to
get psychophan you know we created
people talk about family and all that
but we actually
had one and they still do uh John's done
a really good job in continuing that
culture using his uh his leadership and
and getting that across the former Duke
head coach Mike shazewski joining us you
know I never thought that I would be
saying that I I didn't know you probably
thought I was going to retire first but
uh yeah I was waiting I held on a few
more years
and uh and I couldn't do it no no
I said this guy this guy's like the guy
at the party that never leaves or the
family that was coming for the weekend
and yeah a month later is still with you
how about you go and surprise the
Cameron crazies and sit in there no no
because it would be uh distracting yeah
distraction also not respectful of what
John's doing like I've tried to
just
go to practice
a few times and if he asked me like if
they were scrimmaging uh
to watch but I'll watch up above you
know in Cameron and uh you know he needs
to have it's his program now and he
needs to have me be there if he needs me
but not be there all the time and you
know I'm still in my same office
uh my wife and I we have lifetime
contracts that do to be ambassadors and
basically Dan we're doing all the
things I did as a coach
except coach and recruit you know like
today you know I'll have uh after this I
have a a zoom with uh The 307th Fighter
Squadron uh the f-15s uh for about a
half hour then I have my my own show my
own radio show
and then I uh on on Sirius and and then
uh a meeting with uh Ann Reed who runs
the children's hospital and you know
we're involved with the we've always
been involved with a lot and so we want
to continue that involvement
when's the last time you talked to Kyrie
Irving
I text him probably
two weeks ago
yeah what are we missing with Kyrie
you know I I'd rather not speak for
Kyrie I love Kyrie you know I have a
great
I think a great relationship with him uh
he's he's really smart and really
talented
and uh and that's the reason yeah as a
result of having this exposure uh
his own shoe which
now Nike has uh uh you know stopped
their relationship uh you know it's a
different world and it's tough to
uh unless you're with the person all the
time it's tough to see how that all that
has influenced but with me
I love him
uh I'm in his corner and I'm there to
help him if he feels I can help him well
I wondered about that sort of balance of
when do I reach out or do I wait for
that person to reach out your former
players yeah well I would always reach
out and give the opportunity if there
was if they wanted more
you know and that's where texting comes
in and and you know he would text back
and but you don't you know the other
thing is jumping in when you don't know
everything
is difficult to give counsel yeah and uh
or counsel your opinion yeah
whether you think that's Council or
whatever and uh but uh uh I do want him
just like any of our players to know
that uh I'm there you know if you what
for whatever and uh
uh you know Kyrie Kyrie actually played
more games for me with the US team than
he did for Duke uh two people takings
and so I got to know him along the way
even though I didn't
yeah we had a good relationship his
freshman year but it wasn't wasn't
playing and uh you know I'll tell you
you know do we have time for a story
about him sure okay so when we recruited
him
top one of the top players and you know
he was born in Australia
so uh his dad played there's dad's a
great guy and uh dread and uh in high
school like when he was 17 18 he had an
opportunity to play and wanted a
youth tournaments
worldwide and he could play for
Australia or the US
and Australia was putting a lot of
pressure on him and uh he wasn't sure
what to do and I said do not do that
play for the U.S and I said it I said
you're going to be one of the
the guards of your generation or maybe
the guard of your generation
and you're going to be the point guard
on the U.S Olympic team in some time
fast forward a place in the world
championships in 14 are our perimeter is
curry Harden and Irving and we bring
Klay Thompson and DeRozan Off the Bench
so I was such a good coach amazing he
did a wonderful job I did WOW underdogs
yeah yeah
and uh uh and then the next and he he
was really good uh and then in 2016 in
Rio
we're getting ready to play Serbia for
the gold medal
and in the locker room they're getting
ready and I I just knelt by him while he
was uh putting on his shoes and I said
you know what's going to happen today
and it's our culture I said you're going
to be I got chills like I said you're
going to be the starting point guard
for the U.S Olympic team and uh a very
like kind of an emotional thing so I
have that level of relationship with
them and I know I know that he has a uh
that he has a good soul and a good heart
and and uh and I love him and uh I I'm
sorry that all this is
you know this is a very unfortunate that
all this is happening I think one
afternoon you should just go down to the
local YMCA and just start yelling at
kids or no you know we live on uh we
have a lot of women we have 14 acres of
land I can just I can just go out
squirrels and deer Birds a lot of geese
you know when you get a lot of geese
they leave behind the box so yeah get
the hell out of here
I might even call I'm gonna get I know
what I'm gonna do the next geese Dan get
out of here all right all right yeah
have you ever been named a goose named
after you
um no I think I was going to be named
after geese Osby of the Harlem
Globetrotters but uh with my game but uh
that's that's about it you know you have
to I I I we haven't talked for a while I
thought you got over the fact that you
thought you had a game coach I could
come down to Duke right now and put on a
shooting Clinic
okay
you want me to help somebody with their
free throws and if you don't want Hubert
Davis has already invited me down to say
you know what let's let's look at this
because you're
you're
incredible
and I got one year eligibility left if
if you don't want to take advantage of
it Calipari will
Izzo will I help people that's what I do
I help
well I'm gonna I'm gonna talk to shires
okay all right now we're talking nil I
you know if somebody wants to hook me up
there you have a pretty good nil going
all right I do I got a damn good nio
um it's great to talk to you and uh have
fun in retirement whatever that means
now I'm I'm really busy I'm happy
I'm doing a lot of speaking for the
Washington speakers for all over the
country and and uh no I'm I'm at peace
with there there's no uh Jay Wright on
my my radio show the first one and uh I
said you haven't you have an itch and he
said no I I said I said I'm I'm 75. I
don't itch anymore
that's a good thing that's a good thing
it is a good thing it's a good thing all
right well yeah as it has been yeah for
me you know thanks for having me on yeah
yeah you know what if if you you're
bored you need somebody to talk to you
know because once you're not the coach
nobody really cares anymore but I you
know
yeah see I that's what I was waiting for
I care I I had to I had to wait a while
for you to say that but
the fact that it was said
means a lot
thank you coach all right great to talk
to you all right bye yeah that's just me
giving back to the community
gonna be lonely nobody's gonna care I'll
give him a call